[موسيقى]
عرب سرحان فتاه اردنيه تعيش في الكويت
واكثر ما اثار اعجابها لدى زيارتها لتركيا
هو مضيق الفسفور امله في مشاهده المزيد من
المعالم المميزه
هناك منذ فتره طويله وانا اشاهد الدراما
التركيه وها انا اليوم هنا لرؤيه جميع
الاماكن التي تم التصوير
فيها
اي مواقع تريدين حقا ان ترينها منزل نور
اتوق لرؤيته ومن المؤكد ان هذه الرحله
البحريه الخاصه اصبحت اكثر شهرا بعد
المسلسل الدرامي
نور بسبب انتشار الدراما التركيه في الشرق
الاوسط اصبح العرب يتوافدون الى تركيا
ليزوروا مواقع التصوير وقاعات
الاوبرا ويبدو ان الدراما التركيه استطاعت
ان تاثر خيال المشاهدين العرب فالكثير
يعتقدون ان ما يميزها هو ملامستها للواقع
ومسلسل فاطمه جول مثلا يحكي قصه فتاه وقعت
ضحيه اعتداء جنسي وهذا النوع من الدراما
يتطرق لبعض المحرمات في المجتمع
الاسلامي نحن بلد مسلم واعتقد ان السبب
الرئيس وراء ازدهار الدراما التركيه
ومتابعه المشاهد العربي لها كونه يشعر انه
يتابع مسلسلا محليا وهنا يكمل جمال الامر
والدراما التركيه تعمل على نشر انماط
الحياه والقيم التركيه وقد اصبح لكل بطل
من ابطال المسلسلات التركيه اسمه
اللامه لدينا مواهب ومشاهير كثر هنا
وبعضهم لا يستطيع حتى المشي في بلدان
الشرق الاوسط لكثره معجبيهم وفي العام
الماضي ذهبنا وجميع افراد الطاقم الى دبي
وابو ظبي وراينا الالاف من الناس ينتظرون
لرؤيه الممثلين واخذ تواقيعهم فهم يودون
الاقتراب منهم ورؤيتهم
فقط المنتجون الاتراك يقولون ان مسلسلاتهم
تتمتع بقيمه عاليه نظرا لارتفاع ميزانيتها
بالمقارنه مع منافسيها من دول اخرى كمصر
وسوريا والكثير من محطات التلفزه تركز على
النجاح الاخير الذي حققته المسلسلات
التركيه فقناه ام بي سي خصصت ثلاث قنوات
من ضمن قنواتها الخمس لبث المسلسلات
التركيه في الوقت الحاضر لم يعد هناك
انتاج كبير في الشرق الاوسط لذلك تميزت
تركيا
بانتاجها ويقول عز بنتو الذي ركه و توزيع
المسلسلات الاكثر شعبيه انه خلال الخمس
سنوات الماضيه تزايدت شعبيه الدراما
التركيه وارتفعت اسعارها 100 مره ليس في
الشرق الاوسط فقط بل في منطقه البلقان
ايضا ويبدو ان الدراما التركيه الكثير من
الفضل في تشجيع السياحه ونشر تقاليد هذا
البلد عبر
الحدود